yo what is up everybody mad we do here
with another video so I haven't made a
video in a while which some of you may
have noticed I'll start with an apology
for that lack content I think I just
kind of burned myself out on Dark Souls
3 or and I really haven't been playing
it much recently and I wouldn't want to
be putting out videos that I'm not
passionate about because the content
wouldn't have been as good or what was
expected so that's why there hasn't been
any more Dark Souls videos or Dark Souls
lore videos even though I know a lot of
you are here for Dark Souls lore videos
I really do appreciate all the support
I've been getting with the dark souls
content i channel basically quadrupled
in size I have multiple Souls videos
with over a hundred thousand views and I
passed 10,000 subscribers I'm actually
probably around 14,000 I think at the
time of uploading this so a huge thank
you to everyone who has watched
commented raided and subscribe for all
of that growth it does mean a lot to me
one of my favorite parts of this YouTube
thing is having people respond to my
content and have a conversation about it
and having to tell more people here to
do that has been really great this is a
bit of rambling but this is more of a
relaxed video so it's fine alright so
we've looked a bit at the recent past
and now let's look at the future of it
so because I've covered a lot of
different games on my channel chances
are I will continue to do so the
majority of the growth has obviously
been dark souls as that's been the
largest growth and it's in the most
recent growth in the most significant
growth but my channel is based on a lot
of games based on tips tricks and
recently lord I've done lower for dark
souls a little bit for Fallout I've also
done tips tricks for dark souls fallout
Witcher 3 Borderlands the pre-sequel so
chances are i'm going to keep doing all
of that stuff not just lure i'm going to
put a survey in the description where
you can let me know what you want we'll
make some more specific categories but
it will generally be mostly a range of
tips and lore as those are the two
things that are basically grown my
channel tour dates today if you go to
the very start my channel I do have some
minecraft let's play so if you want to
see a young me post bad minecraft videos
you can go ahead and check that out but
the stuff that I'm proud of the stuff
that has actually garnered me advance
and growth is borderlands tips Witcher
tips fallout tips a little bit
follower dark souls tips tarsals Lord
that's my bread and butter however if
you have other suggestions on sup you
want to see or think that I would be
good at or other specific games you
think I should do lower tip son or I
should keep doing it here you don't want
to go to the survey whatever you can
leave all that down in the comments
section since I will be looking to the
survey but obviously I'll be still be
looking at the comment section so yeah
that's basically the video it kind of
rambling kind of thoughts all over the
place I appreciate you guys watched it
this far again a big thank you for all
the support ten thousands of these I
guess supposed to be a big milestone so
wolf for that I I do really appreciate
it and yet so I will see you in the next
video thank you for watching peace out
you